[Music]
thank you
[Music]
sir my name is Sam snipe I'm looking for
a job as a reporter photographer and I
thought possibly you might have
something to offer
well I am looking for a man but scoop
magazine hires only the best he's got to
be good enough to get the story I want
on a female who has a reputation of
being the most dangerous criminal in the
world her business is robbery and
cold-blooded murder I want a story and
exclusive pictures on her hangout and
how she operates would you like to try
out this assignment
yes sir I sure would but who is this Dan
they call her and the awful her gang is
worse than the famous mom Barker gang
she's a thief any killer she stops at
nothing scoop must expose this vicious
criminal it may be a tough assignment
but if you can get the story we want
you're hired it's up to you
well if that boy brings back a story on
and the office will surprise me if he
does he's got a job for life
[Music]
gosh how can I find it well this is my
big chance I gotta find it I see a
pistol pack and gun mold a bubble dancer
or or a beautiful spy
oh just my luck you don't even know
where to look what does he think I am
anyway a detective
I'll have to keep my eyes open and not
miss a lead
hey what's this She's Dangerous get her
before she gets you and an awful an
awful ease mosquito spreads malaria say
I wonder if that could be anything awful
could a little mosquito be that
dangerous
yeah it sounds like a screwy idea but I
can't afford to pass up a lead
good morning sir I'm Sam snipe from
scoop magazine
scoop magazine huh what can I do for you
well I'm out to get a story and the most
dangerous female in the world she's
known as and the awful and she's a
murderous that's all I know about it but
I saw the poster of the anopheles
mosquito in your window and I had an
idea she might be the one I'm looking
for if you're looking for a dangerous
female you're on the right track
she's a robber and a killer she murders
millions of people each year
it's time people got wise to the
anopheles mosquito and the health
department will be glad to help you
expose her
golly she must be quite a girl sounds
like she's the one I'm after tell me
more about her
you see She carries malaria from the
sick person to the well person then the
well person gets sick and can't do a
full day's work
farms and factories don't produce and
people lose money the farmer who has
malaria may want to work but can't the
malaria germs the anopheles mosquito
gives him destroys blood and keep him
weak and run down
hey this mosquito must be in the awful
hey can you give me the dope on her yes
but uh I prefer that Mr Bradford our
expert on insects give you the
information
Mr Bradford uh this is Sam snipe a
reporter from scoop magazine he wants a
good story on the anopheles mosquito
will you give him some assistance uh
sure if I am I'll be glad to help you
bring the camera and let's go
why are we going into the country Miss
Bradford I thought most gangs operated
in the city oh but Anne and her gang are
different sometimes they operate in the
city but most frequently they commit
their crimes in the country within one
mile of their birthplace
but let's start at the beginning there
are several different plans of anopheles
mosquitoes in the United States we are
primarily interested in the anopheles
quadromeculitis called quad for short
they are so named because of the four
dark spots on their wings
they are also known as the mosquitoes
that stand on their heads in this way
they differ from the common pest
mosquitoes
but where do they come from and and how
do they get the start they're like
chickens they start out as eggs bad day
Keith what a rotten star can you show me
some of those eggs
this is just the kind of place and likes
to lay her eggs no old rain barrels have
been cans for her other mosquitoes like
these but not ants she prefers a pond of
quiet water with plants growing in it
and lots of floatage to feed and protect
her young as they develop
the mother mosquito lays her eggs on the
water surface one at a time groups of
these eggs may form patterns on top of
the water
if we look at these eggs under a
magnifying glass we see the floats along
the side that hold the eggs on the
surface
after about two days the eggs hatched
and out of the tips pop little Lobby
commonly known as wiggle tape
we'll dip for some of these Lobby and
take a good look at them
looking at the malaria mosquito wiggler
from above we see the short breathing
tube near the Tail the feathery hairs on
its tail and along the sides of its body
and the brushes like a mustache on its
face
when we look at the mosquito larvae from
the side we see that the malaria
mosquito wiggler floats just underneath
the water surface wiggle Tales of common
mosquitoes that don't carry malaria lie
at an angle beneath the water surface
and have a long breathing tube through
which they take in air
when this little fella gets hungry it
turns its head and uses its mustache to
brush the food into its mouth it feeds
on Tiny plants and animals until it gets
too big for its britches
then out his pot it would cost a lot to
keep this young and enclosed since it
outgrows it to three times in about one
week
many wiggle bears are killed by fish and
insects those that escape turn into
tumblers which scientists call pupix
tumblers don't eat but they get air
through their breathing trumpets they
detect light through their eye spots and
can swim away from their enemies by
means of the panels on their tails
after two days the full grown mosquito
struggles out of the tumbler shell and
leaves her home in the water
when Anne emerges her legs are shaky and
her wings are wet so she stands around
on the water until she dries and then
flies away
and childhood days are short
in about two weeks he has grown from a
tiny egg through the stage of being a
Lobby then a pupae to an adult mosquito
ready to begin her career of crime
well is it the only uh only the female
monopolies that's considered dangerous
it takes both to raise a family but only
the female can transmit disease well
that's strange why
[Music]
the male doesn't bite he prefers to suck
the nectar from plants
[Music]
but the female she's blood-firsty then
it's a female you have to be on guard
again well how do you tell the
difference
well the female had simple antenna of
feelers while the antenna of the male
are quite pushy but you don't have to
worry about recognizing a male he won't
bother you
and it's dangerous because she gives
people malaria but but how does she do
it this is tied up with her family life
so let's go on with the story
mating occurs within a few hours after
the adult mosquitoes emerge males may be
seen at dusk swarming around a bush
Mound or Haystack until the females
appear
every year is Leap Year for them and
flies into the middle of the Swarm and
grabs herself a male and away they fly
together
time passes and end craves blood
and his developing eggs and before they
can mature she must have a blood meal
she has a choice of cattle horses or
people people who are careless enough to
let her get them a choice of time before
attack is during Dusky hours or dark
is just what she's looking for a house
with a torn screen it's an easy way for
Anne to enter
foreign
[Music]
in bed sick with malaria she's a bit
pale but she has blood and Anne's too
hungry to be choosy she lights on the
girl's arm at an angle and stands on her
head as she places her beak ready to
strike
now her needle-shaped beak pisses her
skin until she finds blood
she pumps saliva into the blood to keep
it from clutting while she drinks she
draws up blood until her tummy is full
along with the blood she swallows a lot
of malaria germs but malaria germs don't
bother ants she's off to her hideout
a cave stable or some cool dark corner
of the house will do foreign has fallen
and wants a place to rest and digest our
blood meals here she is full grown and
stuffed with blood
after resting Aaron lays her eggs in
just such a spot as this and goes out
again in the evening in search of Mob
Life
this is when she does her dirty work
remember where she got her blood before
from the little girl who had malaria
inside of Anne the malaria germ she
drank with the blood have not been
digested but have been growing and
multiplying by now they have worked
their way into her saliva
farmer Jones and his family are resting
after A Hard Day's Work they're all
healthy now but foolish to be sitting
out in the evening exposing themselves
to the anopheles mosquitoes they won't
stay healthy long with Anne around she's
got what it takes to make them sick
foreign
[Music]
she pumps the malaria germs along with
her saliva right into Kayla's farmer
Jones
in a few weeks he will be sick with
chills and fever and won't be able to
make that crappie's counting arms
so Aaron goes on carrying malaria from
the sick to the well
see that out of some Gap I'd sure hate
to run it around a dark knight but wait
till I write my story for scoop magazine
I'll expose her dirty tricks I'll warn
people of ours
boss I got a great story and waiting to
see the pictures I took I got that and
they all recovered from every angle I
got her in her Hideout action shots of
her doing dirty work okay okay calm down
and write it up if it's good enough
we'll use it
I mean I just gotta tell people about
how she multiplied from pools and ponds
and spread malaria
boy this is a great story
when people read scoop magazine and find
out how the anopheles mosquito carries
malaria steals energy and time and
murders millions of people they'll take
action against suspicious criminals
they'll stop this winged Menace from
spreading her shadow of poverty sickness
and death over the world
[Music]